[Musik]
am 12 september 1921 liebe hörerinnen
und hörer also vor genau 100 jahren vor
erscheinen dieses podcasts wurde im
polnischen lemberg der autor stanislaw
lem geboren zu sagen er habe science
fiction geschrieben ist ein bisschen
kurz gegriffen mit seinen romanen
kurzgeschichten und essays bewegt er
sich irgendwo zwischen technik
philosophie utopie und satire um diesen
autor sollte es heute gehen außerdem
haben wir danach unsere drei fragen
gestellt die autoren steht gerade mit
ihrem roman die nicht sterben auf der
longlist für den deutschen buchpreis
man trifft in seinen erzählungen unter
anderem auf rebellische roboter auf
künstliche intelligenzen und virtuelle
realitäten und vor allem auf menschen
die mit all dem schönen fortschritt
irgendwie zurechtkommen müssen genaueres
über stanislaw lem über seine zeit und
vor allem über seine literatur weiß
unser kollege und unser haus experte für
nicht realistisch literatur dietmar dath
im übrigen ebenfalls auf der longlist
mit dem schönen titel gentzen oder
betrunken aufräumen schönleber dietmar
das zurzeit für uns hast habe ich immer
für euch gar nicht sagen man hat hier
einfach generell keine zeit mehr das
freut mich sehr dietmar bär ist dieser
stanislaw lem wie würdest du ihn
einordnen zwischen literatur philosophie
technik utopie und so weiter also es
gibt mindestens zwei stanislaw lem
der erste ist der der anfang der
fünfziger erfolgs polen bekannt wurde
als ein autor von etwas das selbst
diejenigen leute als science fiction
glaube ich erkennen und anerkennen
könnten deren vorstellung davon was das
sei irgendwie rein aus raumpatrouille
orion und irgendwelchen blinkenden
flippern mit ufos und robotern besteht
das heißt es war so eine aufbruchs
literatur wir müssen unsere menschlichen
werte von frieden neugier auf neues und
immer größere erweiterungen unserer
möglichkeiten ins all tragen und so das
sind dann bücher wie die astronauten
oder
auf deutsch ist das ding glaublich gast
im weltraum ich komme deswegen auf diese
beiden titel weil es dazu auch filme
gibt also der zweite lemm der
schwermütige schwerblütige
philosophische nachdenkliche
pessimistische manchmal auf depressive
denen die meisten leute als filmland
kennen lernen nämlich über solaris
entweder von tarkowski oder von
soderbergh der ist eben auch durch filme
bekannt geworden jedenfalls bei den
vielen leser faulen menschen die uns
nicht zuhören und der erste aber eben
auch da gibt es auch filme da gibt es
den film der schweigende stern von 1960
das ist die verfilmung der astronauten
das hat der kurt maetzig gemacht das war
die erste kollaboration
zwischen ddr und volksrepublik polen was
das kino angeht und der film ist
deswegen interessant weil er den frühen
lässt sich perfekt darstellt und so dass
man in der kürzest möglichen zeit dann
wahrnehmen und wenn man ihn nicht mag
eben auch vergessen kann weil das ist
halt ein film und von 90 minuten da muss
nicht viele bücher lesen und lem selber
hat über das zugrundeliegende buch
später sehr gespottet er hat diese ganze
frühe phase die so sagt lasst uns die
welt erkennen und dann verändern was
natürlich auch gut in so eine symphonie
des sozialismus passt das ja klar
technik optimismus gehört ja fast von
anfang an dazu schon von marx ja so
jetzt übernehmen wir die fabriken und
dann wird alles toll und
leben sagt dann also solche sachen wie
ja das war ganz braves zeug und dann
hatte ich irgendwie so eine
internationale raumschiffs besatzung da
ist dann noch ein kluger chinese dabei
und ganz patente russe und so weil das
ja auch die zeit war wo das
sozialistische lager sich noch überlegt
hat also dass die die staaten des
warschauer vertrags ich noch überlegt
haben ob die chinesen sich auch dazu
gehören also es dann teuer chinese und
der film hat wirklich seine bonbons
strahlkraft also für leute die die nicht
leicht davonlaufen wenn irgendwas
optimistisch und zupackend und und und
auch heiter und und einfach
voller zutrauen zum menschlichen gehirn
und zu den menschlichen händen ist da
kann man eine menge spaß mit haben also
bis hin zu einem punkt dass eigentlich
diese schwermut oder dieses kostet doch
sehr viel das universum zu entdecken und
es kostet menschlich sehr viel wurde
sogar vorkommt aber dann in gewisser
weise
vom optimismus aus sozusagen gesiegt
wird es gibt eine ganz hübsche stelle wo
ich glaube in den filmen der japanerin
sagt ja aber mein mann ist dabei
gestorben irgendwelche
satellitenantennen einzurichten pipapo
und der chinese dann sagt ja aber sie
sind doch so berühmt und in china jedes
junge mädchen das ich für wissenschaft
interessiert klammer auf also überhaupt
jedes junge mädchen hat ja ihr buch und
erzeugen so also das war so diese sicht
auf die welt und bisschen finster ist
tatsächlich schon der andere dieser gast
im weltraum da gibt es auch einen sehr
guten film meiner meinung nach einen der
besten science fiction überhaupt filme
überhaupt e car ex1 heißt er und ist von
jendrik pollack den vielleicht viele
kennen werden als den filmischen urheber
von pan tau dass dieser wunsch erfüllen
de mensch mit der melone
also dass der frühling das ist der lärm
der sagt wenn man sich mühe gibt dann
kann man alles verstehen und dann kann
man das auch irgendwie bewältigen usw
und der spätere lemm sagt dann ja
pustekuchen
so praktisch wie ja als
naturwissenschaftler hätte ihm das
gefallen wenn man sagt es gibt jetzt
neuere ergebnisse dass ihr genauer du
die zeit misst desto mehr wird die
unordnung außenrum das wäre so ein satz
der gut passen würde zu diesem späten
depressiven und finsteren der dann sagt
nicht mal die naturgesetze sind konstant
das heißt selbst wenn wir sie erkennen
könnten können sich dann auch wieder
ändern und wenn es dann gar keinen
festen grunde boden gibt ja was gibt s
dann und was es gibt in der tat beim
späten lemm ist diese nüchternheit die
sagt wenn es schon allen alles keinen
zweck hat dann schauen wir der wahrheit
aber wenigstens ins gesicht und erkunden
das was das heißt also sozusagen er sagt
nicht nur das ist ein abgrund und das
ist eine schlucht sondern es sagt lass
uns doch mal gucken wie tief die ist so
und abgesehen von diesen ideen die er
hat was für ein politisches verfahren
wendet er denn eigentlich an um das zu
verpacken und uns dazu bieten das erste
ist das was glaube ich ihn so geeignet
macht für viele
nämlich dass er sehr oft diese haltungen
es sind ja nicht nur thesen und
behauptungen und ideen sondern zur
haltung wie zb es hat einen zweck oder
es hat keinen zweck in so kleine szenen
packt also gast im weltraum endet damit
dass dann da irgendwie jemand sitzt und
rausguckt und da leuchtet irgendwie
magellansche wolke was als ich klein war
und das gelesen habe ich dann irgendwie
so erhoben hat wieso die sanduhr auftakt
zu einer ganz großen epischen symphonie
oder so hat immer so kleine so kleine
pictures so so die die die praktische
anweisungen selbst für faule kameraleute
wären zu sagen da das sieht aber
bestimmt geil aus oder eben bedrohlich
oder fenster oder schrecklich oder so
also diese erzählung an danke in der es
dann heißt ja die katastrophen sind
nicht unvermeidlich endet damit dann wie
wie schlammig schlug ich graue rotbraun
der maus eigentlich ist und so dass das
eine das er also sehr bildhaft ist das
andere ist er ist auf eine art kreativ
die für mich die ganze ost science
fiction die eben nicht im westlichen
sinne da komme ich gleich darauf eine
science fiction ist
kennzeichnet also er wird ja immer so
alleine gestellt was so eine typische
faulheit glaube ich von unserer 1
kritiker für ton ist
literaturwissenschaftler ist dass man
sagt die großen einzelnen genies dann
lese ich da den werkkatalog runter und
dann muss ich nicht weiter wissen was
damals so lebens mäßig los war oder ob
es eine szene gab es gab in polen szene
es gab den janus seidel mit mit z am
anfang es gab den adam wisniewskis merck
die teilweise auch sehr lemm es
geschrieben haben nur sozusagen immer so
ein bisschen so wie es 10.000 bands gibt
die sind wie metallica aber irgendwie
nicht so knackig also macht sie das
gefühl hat ich sind auch schon fast lemm
aber dann reicht es nicht ganz dazu und
die machen aber alleweil du nach
politischen verfahren fragst so sofort
schöpferische dinge also wenn er zum
beispiel sagt das was wir virtual
reality oder cyberspace nennen würden
also simulierte errechnete welten die
dann mit einem datenhandschuh und seine
brille erfahren kannst das nennt er dann
fand o matic weil es phantome sind weil
es schäden sind bei dem seidel gibt es
irgendwo so menschen mit ganz kleinem
kopf und fast keinem hirn die aber
irgendwie körperlich was drauf das sind
die muskulatur
und diese art von knackigem sozusagen
eben nicht marken coca cola microsoft
namen sprechen sondern so eine
dichterische namen sprechen dass mit
diesen technischen wörtern aus der
prognostik und aus der ja immer so was
mit ist tisch und ick und
automat mit diesem vor nase pfarrer
dingsbums mit dem was sozusagen die
wissenschaftler auch neue konzepte
einführen so damit haben die gearbeitet
und das interessante daran für uns würde
ich sagen für uns west nasen und für uns
nasen nachdem nach dem restlichen
sozialismus ist dass es dadurch nicht
eine frische hat von zukünftig kite die
bei uns immer zugedeckt ist davon dass
diese ganzen englischen ausdrücke für
science fiction konzepte uns eigentlich
das gefühl geben hier werden schon
wieder produkte beworben also wenn du
anfängst nanotechnologien 90ern das ist
jetzt mano coating für einen scheiß
autos und spreche dass es nicht so
schnell dreckig wird
cyberspace ist ja wissen wir schon da
will wieder irgendein jeff bezos oder
irgend ein blöder twitter heini mir was
an drehen oder dass ich für umsonst
irgendwie clique und und wert generieren
und wenn die ganzen sachen eben keinen
namen haben bei denen wir schon immer so
warenzeichen hören sondern so
dichterische nahmen die so bisschen
getrunken und kritik und bucklig und und
selbst gezimmert klingen und mit
tesafilm und so alt wie so die leute die
im osten keine ersatzteile gekriegt
haben und dann halt alles selber
reparieren mussten dann hat es so eine
erste bank sagt man heute glaube ich
also es hat so eine knatternde
knautschige
teilweise angerostete es ist schon es
ist ein handy wo man noch kurbeln muss
oder so und und das gaffa tape das den
laden so genau und es gibt dem ganzen so
ne kernig kite und zunächst eine höhere
pixel zahl und so eine so eine größere
das riecht mehr nach was und so das ist
nicht so dieser sterile plastik gummi
marketing kram von apple oder so den den
dass das westliche zeug hat auslöst wir
haben es jetzt gerade schon von ost und
west und als slam schrieb war der kalte
krieg ja gerade in seiner kältesten
phase wir wurden seine bücher den
aufgenommen in ost und west er hat es
ist sozusagen da ist eine ironie
schleife drin und zwar
erstaunt man ja wie überhaupt diese
ganzen ost er hätte gesagt
wissenschaftliche fantastic also hat
irgendwann mal gesagt das ist keine
science fiction das wissenschaftliche
fantastic wobei das natürlich so eine
abgrenzung sting ist wie wenn ein porno
regisseur sagen würde das sind keine
pornos sondern das sind sinnlich
erotische lichtspiele was ich drehe oder
so aber
in der tat geht es glaube ich dem lämmer
an der stelle halt darum sich von von
dieser westlichen literatur die er rein
optimistisch gelesen hat deswegen machte
er dann auch die die nicht rein
optimistisch waren leute wie philipp
kritik oder so es sich davon irgendwie
abzugrenzen und es ist ganz erstaunlich
zu sehen wie
wie viel man den leuten sozusagen
durchgehen ließ an kritik an verwaltung
und zentralisierung und all den dingen
die sozusagen im westen ja schon immer
gesagt wurde das ist das ist der
ostblock der wisnewski snare kriegt
irgendwie einen preis für das buch
roboter
zum soundsovielten bestehen der
volksrepublik und in dem in dem buch
geht es eigentlich nur darum wenn der
staat das alles oder wenn wenn sozusagen
das ausgerechnet und geplant wird alles
das doch alles scheiße und so und lem
hatte dazu aber eine meinung und das ist
ganz interessant da ist nicht da ist
nämlich eine schlaufe drin wie ich schon
sagte man kann dann in briefen lesen
dass er sozusagen ein teil seines
verlustes des respekts gegenüber diesem
sozialistischen projekt ist in der tat
davon genährt dass er das gefühl hat es
geht ihnen gar nicht um sozialistisches
projekt sonst würden sie auch kritik
daran ja viel übler nehmen also so nach
dem motto 'wenn ich verboten würde würde
ich den staat viel ernster nehmen als
wenn ich jetzt in großen auflagen
gedruckt werde denn es war tatsächlich
so du konntest eigentlich relativ viel
sagen darüber dass du nicht so ein start
willst du kannst nur nichts gegen die
russen sagen das heißt lem hat also
irgendwann das sieht man in den briefen
sondern seine auffassung entwickelt im
grunde kann das sozialistische dann ja
nur tünche seien für einfach eine
vormachtstellung einer nation also die
sowjetunion sozusagen sagt uns was läuft
und wir können den ganzen tag sagen karl
marx waren dumme solange wir nicht sagen
die in moskau keine ahnung sollen uns in
ruhe lassen und das heißt er sah dass
mehr und mehr
japanisch vielleicht oder oder neil ist
ist jedenfalls abgeklärt als ein ding
das sozusagen versprochen war als ein
programm ding und dann aber zu seiner
blöden außenpolitischen blog bildungs
kiste wurde die er halt noch verachten
konnte und da ist sicher auch ein
bisschen was dran also gerade info in
polen war es ja so dass
inhalte wenn man sagt sozialismus ist
ein emanzipatorisches ding oder so viel
weniger wichtig waren als in der tat
diese diese hier herrscht ruhe und
ordnung nummer ab einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt und ein sehr kluger mensch wie
lem kann mit dem gebot
um 18 uhr es ist es still nicht so viel
anfangen weil in ihm ist es halt nie
still also in seinem universum ist es
nicht still und mit seinem kopf auch
nicht der muss halt fragen stellen und
das lustige ist tatsächlich dass es
dadurch aber natürlich irgendwann auch
ein bisschen was repetitives hat also
ich würde mal so sagen ich will nicht so
drastisch sagen kennst du ein buch
kennste alle aber diese späten bücher
die drehen sich schon so ein bisschen im
kreis in es wird versprochen
kommunikation mit fremden mit maschinen
oder mit außerirdischen bringt was aber
geht ja gar nicht es wird versprochen
die technik ganz lösen aber kann sie ja
gar nicht und so es ist es so ein
bisschen
er entwickelt sondern haft neurose
irgendwie mit diesen problemen in denen
er sitzt und das einzige was ihn dann
doch wieder abhebt von leuten die
einfach nur ihr kümmerliches trauriges
lied singen ist dass er auch das immer
weiter treibt und sozusagen sagt na ja
also das letzte mal ich gesagt sprache
bringt nichts wisst ihr was denken
bringt auch nichts wisst ihr was leben
bringt schon nichts materie ist doch
scheiße so und also diese die sagt
dieser dieser zog sozusagen erst im
hardrock zu erfinden dann zu sagen es
muss schon ein richtiger heavy metal
sein dann muss es beat mittel sein dann
muss es black metal sein muss es das
mittel sein und am ende sind es
irgendwie ohne artikulierte schreie der
körper kann ich und artikuliert sind
sondern an deren artikulieren als
schreie es sozusagen sehr viel sehr viel
energie wendet und es ist einfach formal
bis zum schluss beeindruckend also es
ist einfach ich suche ja an diesen ich
suche an diesen kritikern ja immer
wahnsinnig gerne die positive vision
was gibt es denn sowas kann man das bei
lem irgendwie sowas
herausschälen ich glaube sein höchstes
ja ich glaube sein höchstes ideales wir
machen uns nichts vor also er sagt so zu
sagen dass du diese alte geschichte ich
vergesse immer wär's mir erzählt hat
aber ich glaube irgendwie bei hans
wollschläger stets irgendwo der
unterschied zwischen tröstung und trost
rüstung ist billig das ist jemand der
die sachs dem kopf so schlimm ist es
nicht oder so wird schon alles wieder
schau mal die vögel ich schau mal die
vögel zum 1 hör mal die vögel ja du
meinst doch wie sieht es aber
so die senne komm runter vom vom rand
des hauses von dem du runter springen
wird es gibt doch so viele schön ist
hier ein überraschungsei oder so das
sind tröstungen und lems positiv um war
wenn es so schlimm ist lasst uns den mut
haben lasst uns das rückgrat haben lasst
uns den verstand die klarsicht und auch
sozusagen die ästhetische
transparenz haben zu sagen ja so schlimm
ist es und das weiß ja jede und jeder
wenn man wirklich ein scheißtag hat dann
ist es oft so die besten freunde sind
die die einfach sagen ja es ganz schön
scheiße und nicht die die sagen noch die
drei hier guck mal auf dem
fernsehapparat läuft schon wieder
irgendwas
ich kann mir helft mir gerade den ja ich
kann mir jetzt gründe vorstellen dass
das lemm damit sowohl in ost als auch in
west gut aber auch nicht gut angekommen
ist
das kann man so sagen ja also es ist so
ich hab ich habe lemme ist einer der
autoren die es in der in der science
fiction ja viel gibt die sonne gemeinde
bilden im sinne von dann wird alles
übernommen also dann wird auch die
perspektive auf die welt übernommen und
so weiter ist nicht so aber ich habe
mich von dem anregen lassen oder das ist
ein gut konstruiertes buch oder was für
ein trip oder so sondern so ist die welt
ja also leute die zum beispiel wenn man
jetzt das den gegenpol nehmen dass adams
hätte dann nur noch witze machen können
so also die fotos das gefühl hast mein
gott dieser mensch ist ein leserbrief an
die titanic geworden weil er zuviel
tages adams gelesen hat und er kann
überhaupt hier kann nur noch herrchen
sagen und solche sachen und genau so
gibt es eben diese leute die sozusagen
dann so in feierlichen tief sind
verfallen war alle möglichen dinge die
so das schönste muss für die wirklich
diese challenger explosion gewesen sein
oder so aber jetzt habe ich 20 jahre bei
lem gelesen es ist alles scheiße und
jetzt fliegt es in die luft ich hab's
euch doch gesagt oder so
das sind sozusagen die unangenehmen fans
die die unangenehmen gegnerinnen und
gegner ist ja auch klar kann man sich
auch vorstellen sind leute die das nicht
an sich ranlassen wollen also die nicht
an sich ranlassen wollen das in der tat
minimum ist ja selbst wenn die technik
ein paar probleme lösen kann und paar
krankheiten besiegen kann und ein paar
klimakatastrophen folgen wieder in griff
kriegt und sodann ist ja trotzdem das
was sozusagen bis dahin passiert ist nie
versöhnt war ein gedanke der den lärm
auch sehr beschäftigt also der in dem
gast im weltraum gibt glaube ich eine
passage wenn wir die utopie schaffen
dann sind ja trotzdem alle die gefoltert
geknechtet missbraucht misshandelt
ermordet wurden die sind ja bleiben ja
dass diese summe des leids bleibt ja und
da gibt es leute die das extrem
irritiert die also sozusagen an ihrem
weltverbesserung sting sei es
technisches als politischer art nur
festhalten können wenn man ihnen auch
verspricht das dann wirklich alles nicht
nur gut ist sondern auch irgendwie immer
gut war weil hatte er dann doch alles
unsinn weil führte ja dann zum
eierkuchen land und für die ist ja dann
irritieren sozusagen und die
lassen dann auch kein gutes haar an ihm
auf eine art die dann genau so nervt wie
die wie die munkel runkel finster duster
fans so also er ist wie viele große
leute halt einfach interessanter als als
eindeutige reaktionen auf ihn sein
können er ist widersprüchlicher er ist
vielseitiger es gibt wie gesagt ich habe
angefangen mit es gibt zwei lämmer und
wenn ich darüber nachdenke gibt es
mindestens 15
lemm hat ja eine wahnsinnig lange
lebensspanne das ist ja auch also bisher
2005 erst gestorben das heißt er hat
eigens für die ersten großrechner
mitgekriegt diesen sozialistischen
aufbruchstimmung und dann tatsächlich
noch das internet an mit mitbekommen
wie hat sich das will hat sich da der
blick verändert auch gerade jetzt so in
den letzten jahren ist ja unfassbar viel
passiert eigentlich auch nachts auch
nachdem
der eiserne vorhang gefallen ist und so
war ja eigentlich auch eine zeitlang
alles alles super und alles friedlich
und jetzt haben wir es geschafft und
jetzt ist er der große konflikt weg und
so wie hat er die zeit da begleitet und
wir haben dann gibt es in sachen
optimismus und pessimismus schwankungen
oder ist das eher so ein großer
desillusionierung prozess bei ihnen also
ich glaube er hat immer dieses
notwendige korrektiv darstellen wollen
auch genau untersuchen wollen und vor
allen dingen erzählen wollen an was
heißt das konkret für leute die leute
ich sage bewusst leute weil es können ja
auch roboter seien also nicht menschen
die dann sozusagen mit so einem schwenk
ins gute oder schlechte konfrontiert
sind also nicht irgendwie auf einer
abstrakten ebene
so viele tourismus mäßig der größte
nutzen für die größte anzahl und soja
schön für die größte anzahl aber wie
gesagt wenn ein paar leute hinten
runterfallen das tut dann trotzdem weh
und er war es dann ganz gut imprägniert
er hat nicht ins und triumphgeheul jetzt
ist die geschichte zu ende oder so so
francisco koyama der westen hat gewonnen
klar er war ja auch ein recht und jetzt
wird alles so wie der westen will oder
so da ist ja nicht eingestimmt ist das
ist ganz undenkbar dass er sowas gut
gefunden hätte sondern er war jemand
dessen so zu sagen was ich vorhin gesagt
habe es immer weitertreiben dessen
grundsätzlichkeit so groß war bei der
auseinandersetzung mit was menschen
hoffen und fürchten und was davon real
ist und wie man herausfinden kann ob es
reales dass er im grunde geschichten
hinterlassen hat und das ist interessant
die sich ganz leicht auffrischen lassen
ganz leicht übersetzen und ergänzen
lassen durch dinge die es noch gar nicht
gab als er diese geschichten erfunden
hat also ich habe jetzt vergessen
welches buches war aber es gibt ein buch
in dem es zum beispiel in gesellschaften
sogenannte ethos fähren gibt wo keiner
mehr was böses darf das ist natürlich
schon die safe spaces und
genauso
also teilweise sozusagen diese diese
diese skeptischen blicke auf es könnte
sich ja noch jemand diese hoffnung
ausdenken aber ich kann euch jetzt schon
erzählen da ist durchspielen kann dass
das auch nicht alle probleme löst und
dann sozusagen spiegelbildlich dazu hat
er eine perspektive erzeugt das sind so
konkrete einfälle wo man sagt ja das
entspricht jetzt dem was wir heute haben
und außerhalb der konkreten einfälle war
es aber so dass man sozusagen durch lärm
lesen so eine perspektive kriegt so ein
gefühl kriegt für für die sage ich mal
andere seite der jeweiligen klingende
münze dass man das dann ganz leicht
umsetzen kann für gegenwarts zeug ich
denke dabei an den film der futuro
logische kongress der davon handelt
unter anderem was in dem buch überhaupt
ist das so heißt überhaupt nicht so ist
sondern nur der mittelteil entspricht er
mit dem buch ein bisschen aber die
rahmengeschichte ist so eine geschichte
dass robin wright als schauspielerin die
rechte an ich selbst sozusagen hergibt
und dann auch nichts mehr spielen müssen
sondern einfach komplett gescannt wird
und computer verfahren so zu sagen sie
dann jede rolle spielen lassen können
also dieses template dieses muster diese
matrix von von der schauspielerin die
sie dann haben der kann man dann einfach
aus einprogrammieren und dann sagt sie
das ein spiel das so weiter und das ist
in der tat sozusagen
eine art zu denken über über den schmerz
den diese person dann hat in dem moment
also ist eine tolle technologie man kann
jetzt man könnte es ja umdrehen und
sagen der ganze mensch ist speicherbar
auch dann wird er nie mehr sterben dann
ist er wenigstens im rechner immer da so
und und lem wäre eben immer der der
diese münze dann umdreht und sagt das
ist die utopische sicht aber die
dystopische sicht wäre diese
schauspielerin ist jetzt arbeitslos und
sie können irgendein dreck mit ihr
machen den sie irgendwie nie selber
gespielt hätte den sie nie hatte spielen
wollen und so weil sie für eine
riesensumme das irgendwie hergegeben hat
und riesensumme heißt ja
sozusagen dass diese ganze daten
geschichte eben ein ganz komischer
handels kapitalismus ist wie wir ja
jeden tag an den social media
geschichten auch sehen und
das hat sozusagen also ich habe oft bei
solchen weiter drei reihen von lem
sachen das gefühl
die sind doch von ihm auch wenn sie
nicht von ihm sind weil die haltung von
ihm ist weil weil die atmosphäre von ihm
ist und das heißt wir haben vorhin
gesagt konkrete bilder dann haben wir
gesagt abstrakte einfälle konstruktionen
konkrete maschinen ein apparat der das
und das kann ein raumschiff das wir der
unbesiegbare nennen weil es die und die
features hat und als drittes aber
verbinden zwischen den bildern und den
erfindungen so eine art sense of live so
eine art gefühl dafür was es heißt in
einer technischen zivilisation sich zu
befinden und da irgendwie auf
fortschritt zu sehen oder zu erkennen
dass er nicht möglich ist und alles drei
sozusagen macht so eine art es gibt
dieses blöde wort kafkaesken über über
kafkas welt sind und ich glaube es gibt
auch so einen lärm ismus es gibt auch
irgendwie so eine lemmy zieht oder so
und ich muss zum beispiel sagen peter
watts das ist so ein kanadischer
schriftsteller gegenwart wo ich gar
nicht wüsste hat der lärm gelesen weil
der ja zum beispiel auch auf englisch
gar nicht so also in europa ist der ist
ist er ich will nicht nur sagen
bekannter sondern auch besser verstanden
worden so besser tiefer aufgenommen
worden in amerika würden sie eher sagen
hat ist doch der mit den roboter
geschichten oder eben der mit solaris
weil sie halt in filmen kennen aber
peter watts hat also 22 bücher
geschrieben plein zeit und eco park sehr
gutes gefühl hast
das ist der ur ur ur ur ur ur ur enkel
von lem dabei ist es noch gar nicht so
lange her so war arbeitet das ist
sozusagen die selbe art die welt zu
sehen und und ich glaube das
futuristische daran ist eben das lemm
sie zu einem zeitpunkt schon zu sehen
kann wo sie so durch technisiert wie sie
in seinen geschichten ist ja noch gar
nicht war also in den 50ern das heißt
den 50ern 90ern wenn du dir das an guckt
was er da gemacht hast oder so
das ist ja wirklich ein anderes ist
nicht nur ein anderes jahrhundert
sondern dass ein anderer planet
und diesen planeten wo wir jetzt sind
den hat er aber schon gesehen wie muss
man sich den menschen vorstellen der das
damals schon gesehen hat
zurückhaltend sagen wir mal so und dann
aber doch wenn man die briefe es gibt
leider nur es gibt es einen brief
büchlein das ist sehr schön das kostet
auf amazon glaube ich inzwischen
lächerlich viel geld weil es ein kleiner
auflage nur war der widerstand der
materie hieß das in einem patt us-verlag
da kann man ihn so ein bisschen von der
verletzlichen seite
kennenlernen die dann auch fast ein
bisschen also man liest es amüsiert man
liest es teilweise auch ein bisschen
abgetönt weil es dann doch so eine
bitterkeit hat die in diesem ruhigen
nüchternen ton in dem er den pessimismus
und und und diese dinge in den büchern
macht dann nicht gehalten ist sondern
eher reizbar ist auf kurzstrecke
sozusagen auch diese ganzen utopisten da
überall lacht diese dumme amerikaner
immer und mein buch ist jetzt schon so
und so viele wochen draußen und ich war
jetzt gerade mein charakter in den
buchhandlungen da ist es schon nicht
mehr was ist das denn also so ein
bedürfnis irgendwie hören sie mir auch
alle zu und sehen auch alle wie schlimm
es ist oder soll ich noch mal ein
bisschen lauter sagen oder so und das
mischt sich dann immer mit zur
beobachtung aus dem polnischen
politischen leben und es ist so alles
eins also dass das so ein scheiß land
ist es dasselbe wie dass sie mich nicht
genug lieben und es ist schon manchmal
so ein bisschen es gibt ja die simpsons
mit dem mit dem großvater von den sinn
der die wolken anschreit alter mann
schreit wollten an und aber lemm denkt
natürlich weiter alter mann schreit die
sterne an
aber es ist so es war es und es war
schon so jemand der da so
dem es spaß machte anderen mitzuteilen
wie wenig spaß er hat
aber die bücher sind ja auch trotzdem
wahnsinnig lustig absoluter wert den der
theologischen kongress noch mal gelesen
gerade in vorbereitung
wie er da in seinem hotelzimmer liegt
irgendwie zugedröhnt aufs museum und
sich kaum zurückhalten kann sich selbst
zugibt boten und es gibt wirklich
wahnsinnig lustige szenen auch wenn am
ende ist natürlich dass wieder alles
kaputt und so aber
bis dahin gibt es einfach sehr sehr viel
komik und
absolut also ich glaube es gibt groteske
und ich glaube es gibt keinen haltbaren
humor in der kunst schon gar nicht in
der literatur
der nicht irgendwie vom bitteren
genascht hat und genauso gibt es außer
so ein paar franzosen die ich nicht
nennen will niemanden der wirklich
finster ist der nicht dadurch lustig
wird so als wenn man es wenn man
natürlich nur von poser ist der sagt ich
finde alles finster aber in wirklichkeit
findet man es gar nicht finster und will
sich nur interessant machen dann hat man
auch kein humor aber die kanzlei
wegschmeißen
ich bin vorher hängengeblieben an diesen
beiden
phasen in die du das wäre ganz grob
unterteilt hast eine eine optimistische
und dann eine pessimistische phase das
ganze lässt sich bestimmt irgendwie
politisch erklären oder also
zeitgeschichtlich sagen wir mal so
erklären lässt sich das auch persönlich
erklären also hat er irgendwie was war
in seinem leben los
kipp punkt oder passt überhaupt einen
punkt oder eine pid zeit eine ganze
phase in der es dann immer düsterer
wurde oder ich glaube es gibt ein innen
und auch diese abwechslung ich glaube es
gibt einen innen und außen aber ich
würde es ihnen gar nicht als ein
familienleben oder im privatleben oder
psychisches leben sehen sondern als
einen von jemand der ja als das erste
was man ja sagen muss ist ja unfassbar
produktiv sind irgendwie 950 trilliarden
bücher oder so und und viele kleine
sachen und so
also leute die zwei bändchen
hinterlassen wovon der eine heißt ach
dieses leben und der andere heißt ist
wieder so nah es ist eine ganz andere
art fenster zu sein und er war schon so
eine sehr fleißig art fenster zu sein
und wie gesagt auch in der frühen phase
die ich optimistisch genannt habe es
sind ja so überlegungen drin wie was
passiert denn dann wenn wir die welt
retten mit all den leuten die jetzt
schon per du sind und so es mischt sich
aber ich würde sagen der unterschied ist
einer den er ja auch selber betont hat
wenn er anfängt dann in späteren
interviews eben zu spotten über diese
frühen bücher ja ich hatte da den braven
chinesen und so das ist alles irgendwie
bonbon und und bilderbuch ich glaube die
wände die passiert ist ist dass man eben
ja tatsächlich
in dieser frühen kalte kriegs phase
nicht so ohne weiteres wissen konnte ob
der moralischen kredit den ja irgendwie
beide seiten hatten dadurch dass sie
hitler zusammen platt gemacht haben wo
auf welche seite der grenze dieser
kredit jetzt fallen würde sozusagen also
dieses man konnte er im osten auch
durchaus davon reden das ist ein damit
der rassentrennung in amerika los und
was ist denn dann später mit
vietnamkrieg gelost und so während wir
sind ja die internationale wir sind ja
die internationalisten und wir sind eben
nicht rassistisch und bei uns in die
antifaschisten und vermittler besiegt
und so genau sehen wir dass umgekehrt
eben im westen gesagt hat ja wir sind
frei und der hitler war es nicht und die
da drüben sind auch nicht und so also
die frage waren noch eine ganze weile
offen welcher weg ist der weg aus diesem
schrecklichen zwanzigsten jahrhundert
mit seinen atombomben und mit seinen
vernichtungslagern usw sein würde und
solange diese frage offenbar war sie
eben auch für lem offenbar hat sie leben
irgendwann geschlossen und ich glaube
jetzt wenn wir über die literatur reden
er hat sie deswegen geschlossen
weil und das nenne ich das innen also
das war jetzt das außen die
weltpolitische lage oder die historische
entwicklung oder wie man das nennen will
also die großformatigen geschichten und
das innen war nicht unbedingt in seinem
herzen oder seinem kopf sondern in
seiner literatur weil er da eben
wirklich sehr viel zeit verbracht hat
sonst machst du nicht so viele bücher
also den denn ein großteil des tages ist
entweder mit tippen oder mit drüber
nachdenken beschäftigt wenn du so viele
bücher machst und in diesem inhalt er
glaube ich festgestellt dass die
geschichten die
dabei rauskommen wenn man sagt wir
schaffen das einen riesigen nachteil
haben sie sind nämlich alles so
textaufgaben mit lösungen aus der schule
also wenn familie fritz sich eine
waschmaschine kauft wie viele raten muss
sie dann bezahlen bewirbt das hat man ja
auch bei isaac asimov oder so einigen
science-fiction-autoren du hast ein mehr
oder weniger vielleicht ethisches
vielleicht politisches vielleicht aber
auch wirklich technisches problem aber
alle probleme musste als technische
probleme darstellen weil das ist eine
literatur grad gattung also schaffen sie
es mit der rakete da hinzukommen oder
kann der computer das übersetzen oder
reichen die spuren um rauszufinden was
die außerirdischen wollen usw das sind
alles so problem löse geschichten und
das war halt einfach irgendwann
unbefriedigend denn als ein mensch der
es gibt ja diesen spruch 'wenn du nur
ein hammer hast sieht jedes problem aus
den nagel
und vielleicht ist bei lem passiert das
spekuliere ich jetzt aber dass das lese
ich so aus den interviews und ausdehnen
und auch aus der farbveränderung ins
dunkel violette die die bücher genommen
haben wenn du irgendwann zu der
überzeugung kommst nicht nur
sind nicht alle probleme geeignet für
dieses werkzeug sondern vielleicht ist
es generell der falsche ansatz die welt
unter dem gesichtspunkt des lösbaren
problems zu sehen also so wie man sagt
okay bestimmte wissenschaftliche
probleme werden irgendwann gelöst wie
sieht wie wie funktioniert verbrennungen
oder wo kommen die kleinen kinder her
aber wozu sind wir da diskutieren sie
jetzt seit sie darüber diskutieren dann
werden wahrscheinlich weiter darüber
diskutieren also philosophie sozusagen
zum beispiel löst keine probleme das ist
vielleicht der antwort auf deine anfangs
frage andrea inwieweit ist das
philosophie insofern philosophie sich
von wissenschaftlichen darin
unterscheiden dass man die fragen ruhig
immer wieder stellen kann dass es nicht
so ist richtige antwort eins mit stern
du kannst nach hause gehen so und und
ich glaube dieses die welt besteht aus
problemen und die lösungen sind das
entscheidende das zutrauen dazu hat er
verloren und das finde ich eigentlich
auch die humanen also vieles daran
erschreckt mich und finde ich sehr kalt
und finde ich nieder ziehen und so der
humor reißt mich genauso mit wie dich
andrea genau aber so dieses diese diese
darkness ist ist auf dauert dann auch
nichts was
wo man jetzt wo man nichts anderes lesen
will sagen wir so also wo ich nicht
sagen wann wird das nicht lesen aber wir
noch was anderes haben aber was
tatsächlich daran glaube ich von
fortdauernder
humaner tiefe ist eben dieses
dasein das im grunde zwei 22 sorten
menschen da anderen davor bei reden oft
in den büchern nämlich die die sagen wir
müssen das lösen das kann man auch lösen
ohne rücksicht auf verluste ich mir das
jetzt aus und dann beginnt das goldene
zeitalter und die anderen stimmen die
sagen
halt mal brems mal ist es wirklich
wollen wir so damit umgehen oder gibt es
noch einen anderen weg also so
gibt es außer recht haben und unrecht
haben nicht auch irgendwie ebenen das
miteinander klar kommen die nicht wie
eine rechenaufgabe sind
es gibt da ja auch immer die kunstfigur
das ihrem team der auch bei ihm so ein
ich erzähler ist und immer sehr viel
durch die gegend reisen und dann trifft
der leute die irgendwie begeistert ist
verkaufen wollen und so das alles löst
oder was irgendwie toll ist ist
er da auch so ein bisschen ist es ein
bisschen seine seine kunst handpuppen
erzähler figur die an stelle von lem
irgendwie fragt als e.on technisch aber
ich glaube schon also ich glaube wie
soll das denn ich glaube schon ich
glaube auch beim piloten briggs ist es
so ich glaube er hat so also der der
klassische trick ist ja dass suchst dir
wie du sagst du eine handpuppe oder so
was also bei lars von trier in den
filmen sind ist es immer die frau zu der
die leute am schlimmsten sind das ist
dann lasst uns so sieht er sich selber
denkt dessen die frau zu der alle so
gemein sind dabei ist daher ein kleiner
dicker aus irgendeinem land da oben aber
gut okay und und goethe eben der wert
eine wenn ich ein totaler idiot wäre
dann wäre ich so sozusagen und und bei
dem ist es nicht wenn ich ein idiot wäre
sondern sozusagen wenn ich bin ich naiv
wäre das heißt gar nicht dass er andere
meinung vertritt als der autor sondern
es heißt sozusagen
damit noch eine geschichte stattfindet
sind diese sind diese raumfahrer figuren
sozusagen noch nicht ganz so abgeklärt
wie der der sie in die situation
reinstellt und wahrscheinlich schon ahnt
wie es ausgeht und das ist dann auch
eine ganz reizvolle spannung also
sozusagen das ist wie wenn man im
gespräch
sagen würde
gut wenn ich jetzt die antwort nicht
schon wüsste würde ich vielleicht sagen
und so weiter so also
kommt in dem tisch vor allen dingen vom
ross runter also weil dieses dieses
dieses die welt durchschaut haben ist ja
auch ein bisschen und ross auf dem man
sitzt das ist ja auch so ein
feldherrenhügel und und es startet sich
sozusagen
nicht nur über den dingen zu stehen
sondern auch in ihn herum zu stolpern
und ja und ansonsten ist das irgendwie
so ein das ist eine ganze ist auch eine
ganz zeitlose gestalt wie so ein
eulenspiegel oder oder so
hat sie zum vater onkels und sohn nils
holgersson / dis /
vertreter für heiz zocken
wenn man jetzt gerade meinen film
gesehen hat der auf einem roman von
stanislaw lem basiert aber auch kein
buch gelesen hat und diese wie viele
milliarden hattest du gesagt 90er vor
sich 19 milliarden bücher vor sich hat
welches von ihnen wäre ein guter
einstieg
es ist halt so ein bisschen wie wo
fahren wir im urlaub hin also klar
kannst du die berge fahren kannst halt
nicht so richtig schwimmen und clark ans
meer fahren dann kann es nicht richtig
klettern und das wirst du auf jeden fall
bereuen also
wenn du klettern willst ließ solar ist
einfach und wenn du schwimmen willst
ließ den piloten parks oder die die
tische geschichten
und und wenn du wirklich verreisen
willst ließ einfach drei verschiedene
ich würde es für das dritte
vielleicht wirklich die astronauten also
schon früher also man kann sich muss ich
ja nicht von lem vorschreiben lassen so
die hat er nicht verleugnet aber hat so
gesagt ja das war mein käse käse ist was
schönes
guter käse sind ja nicht irgendwelche
kraft schallplatten aus der fabrik
dann hören wir mit dem käse auf vielen
vielen dank lieber dieter für dieses
unzählige gespräche gerne mit butter
danach rekord steht mit ihrem roman die
nicht sterben im märz bei penguin
erschienen auf der longlist zum
deutschen buchpreis
hier haben wir diesmal unsere fragen zum
schreiben und lesen bestellt zuallererst
warum sie schreibt auch für mich ist das
eine große freiheit ich bin in einer
zeit der sprachlosigkeit aufgewachsen in
der diktatur in der kommunistischen
diktatur in rumänien
als jeder jeder misstraute weil ihr der
verrat sich ja meistens verheerend
auswirken konnte und für mich ist
dieses finden der richtigen worte für
das was man spürt was man was man in
sich trägt was man
anderen mitteilen möchte mal was man
anderen
mitgeben möchte eine eine große freude
ist es eine es ist die gleiche freude
eine ähnliche freude eine ganz andere
freude in der rumänischen wie in der
deutschen sprache
es ist gleich in welcher sprache
man sich ausdrückt wichtig ist dass man
das man etwas sagt dass man die
richtigen worte findet dass man
so den den richtigen tonfall findet
dass man das dass eine kommunikation
gelingt
ich habe ich sehe da keinen unterschied
ob
ich ihn auf rumänisch rede oder auf
deutsche darauf endlich auf ganze sich
wichtig ist dass das was was ich ja
unbedingt kommunizieren möchte
kommunizieren kann
wer ist ihr erster leser oder ihre erste
leserin und wie kritisch darf er oder
sie seien
sehr kritisch mein erster leser ist
der schriftsteller perikles monioudis
das ist mein ehemann
im lese ich lese ich manchmal das was
ich schreibe vor oder er darf ein buch
lesen sobald ich es beendet habe wir
haben zusammen auch einen kleinen verlag
den telegramme verlag seit zwei jahren
und lesern auch die mobilen man viele
manuskripte wie wir die wir bekommen
einander vor und auch bergers liegt mir
seine bücher vor oder seine seine texte
seiner seine essays und
kritik wird sehr geschätzt und
ehrlichkeit natürlich
wobei hier natürlich immer eine sehr
konstruktive
kritik
[Musik]
also damit man sich gegenseitig nicht
ermutigt
es geht nicht um anmutigen
natürlich ja ja ja also ich glaube
kritik
gute kritik ist nicht nicht verletzt
es geht um die um die richtige
kommunikation
es geht darum ob das was das was gesagt
wird
verständlich ist
berührt
ein jahr den den gewünschten effekt
walter
also da da habe ich das glück mit einem
schriftsteller
wie im gleichen haus zu wohnen
wir reden schon beim beim ersten kaffee
beim frühstück über die literatur und
unser letztes gespräch manchmal ist auch
handelt auch von von büchern und von dem
was uns was uns berührt von gesichtern
also
wir
werden uns jeden tag über über literatur
aus
und haben auch einen großen an in einem
großen kreis an nitrat innen und
literaten also ich
habe jahrelang
lesungen organisiert in zürich
monatliche lesungen und und habe
immer viele kolleginnen und kollegen
getroffen also
wir jetzt an den regen austausch
das klingt traumhaft
ja
ja ist es auch eigentlich ist es eine
gnade dass man das was einen begeistert
eine begeistert
zur
hauptbeschäftigung machen kann ja
welches buch würde ihn als erstes
einfallen wenn ich wenn ich sie nach
einem buch frage dessen lektüre sie oder
ihren blick auf sich selbst oder ihren
blick auf die welt verändert hat
thomas manns mario und der zauberer hat
mich
nachhaltig beeindruckt hat mich ja
überall
über die macht
die über die manipulation
nachdenken zum nachdenken gebracht über
über das was ich erlebt habe und was
andere auf ähnliche art und weise erlebt
haben oder gerade erleben
und über die die wege
sich aus dieser
manipulation aus
dieser gewalt zu befreien
und überhaupt thomas mann
beeindruckt und
hypnotisiert mich
durch
den meisterhaften umgang mit der sprache
aber es gibt natürlich auch andere
bücher also ich bin nicht
der mensch eines einzigen buches ich ja
ich liebe else lasker-schüler ich habe
immer die ja den arthur aron muss lesen
können also immer wieder
gelesen weil mich diese geschichte über
über toleranz
so so so bewegt
ihn immer schon bewegt hat also seit
seit der schulzeit als ich ja das buch
zum ersten mal entdeckt habe
und bis heute hat sich
nichts an meiner begeisterung
geändert
und natürlich ich habe auch viele viele
zeitgenössische
kolleginnen und kollegen die die ich
sehr schätze und auf deren
bücher ich immer warte deren texte ich
mich freue ich habe eine viel leserin
eine
begeisterte leserin und da ich glaube
dass man schreiben in der verlängerung
dieser leidenschaft wird das lesen
an starten steht
und sie sind eine wieder leserinnen ja
so wirkt es wenn sie sagen dass thomas
mann sie immer wieder oder else
lasker-schüler sie lange begleitet war
wirklich ich das mache ich das mache ich
oft ich lese bücher die
mir gefallen haben
oder die mich irritiert haben die die
mich bewegt habe die mich beschäftigt da
man an einem zeitpunkt meiner biografie
immer wieder um mir aus der
vergangenheit wieder zu begegnen also
literatur bietet uns ein wunderbarer
anlass um über uns nachzudenken über
über die entwicklungen die wir machen
über die zustände in denen wir gelebt
haben
über die denkweise die sich vielleicht
geändert habe
also ich liebe es bücher wieder wieder
und wieder zu lesen
gibt es denn ein buch von dem sie sagen
würden das hätten sie gern schon viel
früher ein erstes mal gelesen gehabt es
gibt ja so diese fantasie man könnte ein
buch einem jüngeren ich empfehlen gibt
es so ein buch bei ihnen
ich
glaube das ist krabat von otfried
preußler
ich habe von otfried preußler als kind
die kleine hexe gelesen natürlich
den krawatten habe ich erst entdeckt als
ich in meinen kindern vorgelesen habe
und ich habe mich gefragt wie ich wie
ich dieses buch als
kind gelesen hätte und ich glaube es
hätte mir sehr geholfen mit mit
aggressionen umzugehen mit der
manipulationen mit dem druck von seiten
der erwachsenen
[Musik]
mit eben in dieser düsteren diktatur
wäre es die passende lektüre
würde mich als kind gewesen hat es das
gegeben in rumänien das buch ja ja es
hat der mann ja ja und außerdem habe ich
die deutsche schule besucht
also ich ja
ich habe auch als kind deutsch lesen
können und wir hatten eine gut bestückt
bibliothek das buch hatte sicher auch
auf deutsch
gegeben
interessant dass sie ein
wenn man kann das gerade noch ein
kinderbuch
nennen und keinen erwachsenen buch das
sie sich für was er sich 16 oder 14 oder
so das lesealter gewünscht hätten indem
man dann so langsam die finger
ausstreckt nach den ersten
richtigen romanen wenn man so sagen kann
ich habe
als ich als ich
aufgewachsen bin hat man eigentlich
nicht so
so so aufgepasst dass man die richtigen
bücher
das alter
einem unter einer zu zu lesen gibt also
ich habe wild durcheinander gelesen
da sonst eine nacht schon schon als kind
und das war für mich die aufklärung
sehr viele legenden
die die griechischen sagen die
ich habe ich und deswegen
denke ich es gibt kein keinen falschen
zeitpunkt um um ein gutes buch zu lesen
man man versteht das was man in dem
alter breite ich zu verstehen und später
kann man ja
das buch wieder jeder lesen und und mehr
verstehen wichtig ist dass man
ja dass man zum lesen findet und dass
man
das dass man ein umfeld hat dass eine
meiner beibringt dass das mana muse
braucht zum lesen das lesen ganz viele
fenster öffnen kann und
ja viel viel freiheit mit sich bringt
am 15 september 2021 ist dana gregor
czaja mit die nicht sterben im
literaturhaus nürnberg zu gast zwei tage
später am 17 september beim innsbrucker
prosa festival und am 23
in rorschach in der schweiz und am 28 in
wettswil am albis
welche titel ist auf die shortlist zum
deutschen buchpreis schaffen erfahren
wir am 21 september der preisträger oder
die preisträgerin dieses jahres wird
dann am 18 oktober gekürt ein paar tage
vor beginn der frankfurter buchmesse
wenn es einen beginn der frankfurter
buchmesse gibt was wir sehr hoffnung
[Musik]
in den schoß und auf unserer seite die
sie mittlerweile wahrscheinlich schon
auswendig mitsprechen können
www.kath.net / bücher - podcast bücher
mit finden sie liebe hörerinnen liebe
hörer weitere artikel zu den themen
dieser episode e mails erreichen uns
unter bücher - podcast faz.de bücher
auch hier mit in den pott catcher in
ihrer wahl oder bei instagram können sie
uns abonnieren licon bewerten wie sie
lustig sind auch diesmal sagen wir
vielen dank fürs zuhören und bis bald
bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]